okay um so let me um
let me say a couple of couple of things
let me just read out
Greg's bio he will be too too humble to
say that but Gregory Sandler is the
president of reason
io a company that puts philosophy into
practice he's the editor of stoicism
today and the producer of half-hour
Hagel series and teaches at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design his popular
philosophy focused YouTube channel has
over 80,000 subscribers his videos have
more than 7.5 million views Wow ah
alright
so Greg welcome over to you thanks for
inviting me in here and you know it's
nice to follow after Bill and Donald
there they're both really you know great
researchers on stoicism and I noticed
that you got Walters name right that's
always difficult to do for Mac so what
are we going to do today we're going to
have lots of people so what we're going
to do is that Greg is going to do a
presentation and then he will take Q&A
now please go ahead they're going to be
lots of questions like every time every
Saturday we get overwhelmed with
questions so if you have questions enter
your questions in chat now okay and keep
on entering the questions and believe me
we will come to all the questions okay
so we'll do that and after the Q&A we
are going to break up into small groups
of about six people each so we can
discuss these ideas and their
application to our lives in great amount
of detail all right so with that back to
you Greg thanks so the topic that I
wanted to talk about is one that's
really central to stoic philosophy in
practice and sometimes gets
misunderstood so I thought this would be
a useful opportunity to do some
clarification and it's very simple -
what's good what's bad and then what's
indifferent which sounds like a you know
very simple trichotomy to work with
and it's it's not just an important
aspect for stoicism as such but you know
virtue ethics in general people are
mixed up about what's good and bad and
how to choose and prioritize between
them but the Stoics introduced this
wrinkle into it using this term the
indifference that was really a
distinctive to them so what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to be giving an
overview of what the classical and
canonical Stoics thought and taught
about what's good and what's bad and
what's indifferent which is a little bit
more complicated than some of the ways
in which it gets presented and then I'm
also going to here and there I'm going
to try to address some common
misunderstandings of these particularly
about the range of the indifference so
what's good and you know and what's bad
from a stoic perspective is what I'm
going to start with and then we'll talk
about how it's connected to other key
concepts and then we'll talk about this
this whole realm of the indifference and
why do they pick this term the
indifference then we'll talk about the
different ranges of value within the
indifference you might say some
indifference are less and different than
others either towards the good or
towards the bad and then we'll talk
about something that the store is called
use and it's how we translate this very
important term crisis I'll talk about
and that'll lead into discussion the
virtues and their relationship to the
indifference and then finally I'll talk
about what gets translated as duties or
appropriate actions and how those are
upon the indifference so if we're
thinking about what's good and what's
bad if we again if we think about virtue
ethics in general we can also say this
about religious traditions and about
psychotherapy which you know has very
early roots in ancient philosophy as
well in some cases part of what the big
project is is helping people understand
and move towards genuine not just
apparent goods and
away from genuine beds or evils and not
just the parent ones to extricate
themselves from from the what's really
bad and so that's an important thing to
sort of bring in another key thing is to
be able to frame things in terms of
higher or lower or greater or lesser
Goods and evils goods and Bad's this is
a matter of prioritization that's just
as important to ethics as figuring out
what it actually is good and bad so you
know if we get away from the Stoics and
we think about pleasure
for example the plaintiffs the most
Italians they would say that pleasure is
a good it's not the good and so we have
to figure out where does it fit into how
we ought to structure our lives we don't
want to reject it entirely but we don't
want to be dominated by the desire for
pleasure stomachs have a different view
on pleasure which we can talk about in a
bit and stoicism seems kind of like an
outlier among ancient philosophy since
they use this term the indifference and
they want a lot of things into it so on
one side we have the things that are
genuinely good and the other side things
that are genuinely bad and then we have
this vast space in between now sometimes
you'll hear people trying to summarize
stoicism and they'll say that stoicism
teaches that virtue is the only good
that's not quite true
the Stoics didn't recognize other things
as being good besides virtue but virtue
is you might say paramount among what's
good so if you look at Cicero and the
stoic paradox is the very first stoic
paradox is only what is noble or only
one is what is right is good you know in
Latin quote Onesimus it in Solem bonum
sa right so a virtues fit in there but
they're not the only thing that's that's
good and the opposite of the virtues
vices are bad but they're not the only
thing that's bad
before I jump into talking about all
this I do want to say a little bit since
people may or may not have a lot of
exposure to stoicism if you want to see
relatively systematic summaries of what
the Stoics did in fact think the places
to go to are Diogenes lay our taste
lives of the philosophers book book
seven areas didymus is epitome of stoic
ethics some of Cicero's works like on
hands-on duties and Tusculum
dissertations and then we have some of
the big heavy hitters that people you
know dive into in their reading about
stoicism Seneca and epictetus marcus
aurelius the meditations are a really
wonderful book but they don't present
things in a very systematic way at all
so you know if you want to do a deeper
dive Epictetus and Seneca are the places
that you go so coming back to talking
about virtues virtues are definitely on
the side of the good and vices are
definitely on the side of the band and
and the Stoics recognized four main
types of virtue and advice they
associated these with what we call the
cardinal virtues wisdom or practical
wisdom depending on how you translate it
temperance justice and encourage and you
know their corresponding vices folly or
foolishness sometimes translated
stupidity you know lack of self-control
or self-indulgence cowardice and
injustice and those things are
considered to be definitely good and
definitely bad by by the Stoics and each
of them is divided into you know you
might call them sub virtues or different
modalities of virtues so for example
earlier today in the stoic parents were
we were talking about courage and Stoics
divine and courage up into a number of
different things only only one of which
actually has to do with dealing with
fear being able to like get through the
daily slog or grind and persevere and
that that's another part of that that
virtue of courage and so these are good
things for us what else are good well
the Stoics thought that certain emotions
or passions were good
or bad actions are good or bad
very often reflecting virtues or vices
people themselves can be classified as
good or bad friendship and hatred as
we're going to talk about in a bit are
good or bad and then of course there's
certain things that you could call them
the overarching states that we're aiming
at like happiness and tranquility
freedom good things right and misery
being disturbed by things slavery or a
lack of freedom those less repent so the
Stoics talked about you know a wide
range of things that are in fact could
have been and they talked about them in
a variety of ways sometimes they framed
it in terms of means and ends or being
productive of things or being things
that were good in themselves sometimes
they use the term participation which is
always a little bit murky when we try to
figure out what it what it means I'd
like to talk a little bit about some of
the other things besides virtues that
are good and bad because that'll help us
then see what's what's neither so the
emotions I mentioned that the Stoics
think that some emotions are good and
some emotions are bad again common
misunderstanding of the stoic says that
the Stoics think that we should get rid
of our emotions or repress them that
definitely is not what they taught but
they thought that some of our emotional
states and emotional reactions are
subversive of reason or resistance or
reason they lead us off into tracks that
are not good for us that and very often
vicious so those would be considered bad
but there are some good emotions the you
poppy and those would be you know for
example caution instead of feeling
irrational fear or anxiety there are
some cases where we want to feel some
fear because it's genuinely rational to
do so or joy another very important
thing the Stoics are not joyless or
loveless or anything like that that is
an integral part of it
so the emotions can fall into both sides
we can also talk about
actions themselves are they in
accordance with our social nature
aligned with virtue and the stomachs
made some you know distinctions are that
we can go into if you'd like to later on
between things that are totally virtuous
and then actions that are just in
accordance with virtue kind of similar
to what Aristotle does in the neck
mccain ethics
Epictetus a very important late stoic
thinker talks about good and evil for
human beings lying within the scope of
our faculty of choice or sometimes it's
translated moral purpose the pro racists
the part of us that does the choosing
which which for Epictetus is basically
the same as the ruling part of ourselves
and another thing that's classified is
as good or bad in a real sense is
friendship friendship and its opposite
hatred or enmity and this is where we
get to something quite interesting
friendship is is classified
strictly speaking as something external
to herself it makes sense right our
friend is not us however we may talk
about being two souls two to one soul in
two body is there any of that
Aristotelian stuff the Stoics recognize
that our relationships are between
separate people but friendship is indeed
something that that is quite good and so
the friends are classified among good
three things not friendship in a lower
sense you know for the sake of what we
might call common benefit where I give
you something and you give me something
but where it's genuine friendship that
is something that is good both in the
relationship and in the state that I
have within myself of being and friendly
with the other person so what then is
the middle part we've got the good on
one side and the bad on the other side
the Stoics talk about indifference and
that's a translation of the Greek term
idea for iya literally meaning the
things that don't make a difference so
these are things there's a lot of
different characterizations of this but
one of them coming from Diogenes layer
taste is that these are things that are
neither good nor evil or bad things that
don't benefit or harm a person and you
know he clarifies that the Stoics
actually say there's two different
meanings to this term and different
there are things that don't contribute
at all to her happiness or unhappiness
we can be happy or unhappy without them
but the use of them in certain ways
contributes to happiness or misery and a
great example this would be wealth which
we'll talk about a bit later you can
pile up as much money as you want and it
won't make you happy if you're already a
miserable person as a matter of fact it
might make it easier for you to be
miserable and do new and exciting ways
and vice versa if you're poor and you
are a good person
somebody who you know is free who's
untroubled being poor is not going to
make things worse but you can use that
money in such ways that it conduces to
to good things right so no amount of
wealth or pleasure or bodily health or
physical attractiveness is going to tip
you over the scale into happiness but it
can be it can be used for that and we're
going to get back to that in just a
moment then there's things that are you
might say even more indifferent things
that have no power to stir our
inclinations or choices towards or
against them and you know if we look at
examples you know the Stoics the Spock
ones are wealth versus poverty pain
versus pleasure health versus illness
living or dying high social status
versus low social status being given
great positions you know being in menial
positions physical attractiveness
physical ugliness all of those things
fall in the realm of the indifferent and
you know
like like I was saying why are these a
different they they can possess a
certain value but they don't possess
enough value no matter how many of them
you you pile up or connect with each
other to make us happier and miserable
and the genuine sense and as persons
they don't make us good or bad either
Epictetus actually has a really nice
sort of deconstruction of mistaken lines
of reasoning when he says people say to
themselves I have more money than you
therefore I'm better than you when
really the only thing that you can draw
as a conclusion is that they can they
combine more things than you can write
these these are not actually connected
and so part of stoic analysis is
disentangling these things from each
other and seeing indifference as
indifference now there's kind of a
common mistake I think that's largely
due to our language we we see this term
indifference you know ending in the
plural and we think that that means we
automatically ought to feel indifferent
towards those things and that doesn't
actually follow for the stoic philosophy
there were some ancient philosophers who
did see things that way but they weren't
the Stoics there's also a tendency to
you know map certain categories once you
start learning about stoicism you learn
about the dichotomy of control what's in
my power what's not in my power
you learn about internals and externals
and it's really easy to say oh well
those all connect up with each other
what's indifferent is what's external is
what's not in my control not completely
those those are overlapping categories
but they're not you might say coinciding
categories so we have to think about
doing difference have any sort of value
at all and the Stoics say that they do
some of them do at least some of them
don't so there are some genuinely in
different matters and I'd invite you to
think about as I go through these
examples think about things that you
don't care about one way or another and
it's not because you're pushing it away
and rejecting it it just doesn't matter
to you at all so some of the classic
examples that the Stoics give whether
the number of the hairs on your head is
even or odd
who cares that doesn't make a difference
to anything that we could possibly think
of you could construe some situation in
which that might matter you know like
let's say the government decides that
all the even-numbered hair people are
going into one field and all the odd are
going into another and then people who
don't have any hair I suppose lead after
the third category for but that's so
artificial it doesn't it doesn't really
connect up with us whether your finger
is straight or bent they say who cares
it doesn't matter picking up something
along the way like a twig or a leaf is
another example that they give now
that's that applies to a lot of things
they really are genuinely indifferent
they have we have no stake in them at
all then in that here's where it starts
to get tricky then there's things that
are indifferent and the Stoics were
willing to say that they were
indifferent but they have some sort of
value and the word that's used there in
Greek is hacia meaning you know
something that has some some sort of
stake some sort of value it's worth
something and they talked about what we
translate as preferred and rejected
indifference so these could have
positive or negative value but they
weren't going to be the sort that would
actually cross the the threshold into
what's genuinely good or bad the place
by the way if you really want to see the
best discussion of this to go to is in
Cicero's work on the ends where he's
having Cato the great stoic stateman and
philosopher presenting the stoic
doctrine on this that's probably one of
the best places to go to book three of
that that worked so a lot of these
indifference do in fact have some some
value some positive or negative value
they don't have the same kind of value
you might actually think about it like a
two-tiered system where you've got you
know what's genuinely good or bad up
here it can really determine whether we
are happy or miserable and then we've
got everything else down here and there
are you know higher and lower with
and we can trade them off against each
other but no matter how much of that we
we accumulate or you know manage to get
rid of we're not going to be happy or
miserable on account of that so how do
we clarify the value that they have them
that's one of the central questions for
the Stoics and one of the terms that
they use that again I think a lot of
people get mixed up about is they they
use this framework of in accordance with
nature or in you know in contradiction
to nature or out of harmony with nature
however you want to translate it
contrary to nature so this is actually a
very complex notion for the Stoics and
when they're using this notion of in
accordance with nature they don't just
mean accepting you know the university
as it is because we're also part of that
nature human beings in our capacity for
development are part of that nature they
don't mean nature in the sense like when
we see somebody doing a bad thing and we
say ah that's human nature you know
people are jerks
that would actually be contrary to
nature for the statics so think about
what a fully developed fully realized
human being would be like and that
provides us with a model for what is in
accordance with nature Arius didymus
tells us that some things can be in
accordance with nature as such others by
participation so he gives us examples of
that having a steady hand and a healthy
body
it's it's the way things want to be
developing but you can you could still
be happy without having a hand that
doesn't shake or a body that's not in
the best shape entirely Seneca in letter
119 tells us that what is good is what
is in accordance with nature but what is
in accordance with nature is not
immediately good as well there are some
things that are that are in accordance
with nature that's that stem from the
kind of creatures that we are and our
interface with the world that aren't
automatically good what's going to make
them good is some sort of connection to
the versions
Diogenes Lee artist tells us that that
indifference that are preferred to
contribute to what he calls harmonious
living he also tells us that some
preferred indifference are because there
for the sake of something else there's
something useful so we might think here
about money which we're going to talk
about again a little bit later money is
not a bad thing it's not a good thing
either it's it's an N different from the
stoic perspective but it's a preferred
indifferent because when you have money
you can use it to purchase things that
you need you can use it to accomplish
tasks that actually are your duties or
moral obligations it can be used within
the service virtue
they can also be misused right a vicious
person with money is in a bad state it's
probably better that they don't have too
much money because they can accomplish
much more harm with it but money can can
actually be you know quite quite useful
it can be conducive to other types of
things that could in fact be a genuine
goods or it can be good for purchasing
other preferred indifference or keeping
at bay other rejected indifference
interestingly another thing that they
talk about as being a preferred and
different and I think this helps to give
us a bit of perspective moral progress
or moral development in in Greek it's
Procope N and we get the the word
Procope taste meaning that the person
who's not yet a sage if there are indeed
any sages but the person who's in the
process of development or studying
stoicism that is also preferred and
different according to the Stoics
because it's not yet there in terms of
virtue and advice Seneca later on in his
letters and letter 82 talks about death
and he says that death isn't indifferent
and he recognizes that it is a hard sell
he says that it's among the things that
are not bad but they have a semblance of
badness there's all these things that we
in our normal natural attitude
view as as bad by themselves even though
if we analyze them perhaps they're not
and it so he says it's not something
that we can easily ignore and the last
thing I'll say about the value of the
difference is that those that are either
preferred or rejected they they do have
a value you might call it exchange for a
transaction in relation to each other so
Diogenes at Babylon and then again this
isn't Cicero's on the ends so that again
wealth is quite good because you can in
fact use it to purchase things that will
make you healthy if you think about
buying medicine right or you can use it
for other things that are preferred
indifference the one thing that you
can't do with it well actually two
things he can't do with it
the one one of them is you can't become
virtuous just by purchasing something
and you also can't keep yourself from
being vicious by accumulating wealth and
spending it but it is so you know it's
very useful for all sorts of other
things and we can say similar things
about our capacities or our skills that
we learn right or our bodily attributes
all of these things are in fact valuable
in some sense they're just at that lower
tier so if we think about what we're
supposed to do with indifference one of
the things that I mentioned a little bit
earlier that's quite important for the
Stoics is what they called crisis in
Greek and in Latin its Lucis and we
translate this typically by the word use
it's a little bit misleading because it
also means dealing with or the attitude
that we take to things or the
application that we make of them and so
Epictetus is actually one of the best
people in talking about this there's
there's an entire chapter in his
discourses it's book 2 chapter 6 that is
devoted it's called on indifference in
things just period EF or e hacen in
Greek and so he's telling us what would
indifference as opposed to indifference
with the plural less means and he gives
you an example of the hypothetical
syllogism so I don't know if any of you
have ever done logic or not probably
quite a few of you can and people do get
worked up about logic believe it or not
you know in philosophy classes and other
venues as well a lot of times that's
probably misplaced because you know in
itself
who cares it's not that important of a
thing the hypothetical syllogism
but the judgments he says that we make
about them they're not indifferent so we
can have something that in itself is
indifferent but the attitude that we
take towards it the approach that we
have the use that we make of it is not
indifferent Epictetus tells us that we
really need to be careful not to be
laksa days ago there's a way we can we
can translate it his term there is MLA
it's not getting care to something we
don't want to be careless when it comes
to different things because the use of
them is not indifferent so we've got
things that are indifferent but what we
do with them the uses that we make of
them is definitely not indifferent and
has a great effect on us morally
speaking in an earlier chapter and in
Chapter five of book two he says that
the materials that we work with are
indifferent but the use that we make of
them is not indifferent and he suggests
that what we want to do is imitate those
who play games and he has in mind a dice
game we don't know exactly what game it
is it clearly it involved counters of
some sort so maybe it was like
backgammon or something and then he also
talks about playing the ball game
and he uses Socrates defending himself
in the wrong court as an example of
somebody who's playing the ball game
well
the game itself doesn't matter as such
but playing it well that is up to us and
that is something important so there's
all these things that are in difference
and in themselves they don't have value
but we give them value by what we do
with them and it can be positive value
or it can be negative value the things
that our indifference could be used well
or badly so you know wealth is an
example we can also think of physical
health it's nice to be healthy right I
mean in this time on coronavirus were
very concerned with it we wash our hands
socially distance I wear a mask when I
go outside I know a lot of my fellow
citizens here in Milwaukee don't maybe
they have a very different attitude
towards physical health and it's you
know it's something that we can decide
to use well or use news poorly I could
use my vitality to rob banks I mean
probably not I probably would be a bad
bank robber because it's not in my skill
set but there are randomly accost people
on the street and knock them down or
things like that so health can be used
in all sorts of ways and we can talk
about all sorts of other examples as
well and this brings us to the issue of
virtue
the Stoics are in you know virtue
ethicists and we'll talk about the
specific virtues of debt one common
mistake that got made not just in the
present but also the ancient world was
thinking that because virtue is good and
indifferent things are not good they're
they're indifferent that virtue would
not be concerned with things that are
indifferent but it would it to be
virtuous would actually be to like push
those things away don't get too
entangled with them don't focus on those
things at all in fact the opposite is
the case for stomachs it wasn't the case
for some other philosophers including
somebody who was very close to Zeno the
founder of stoicism he had a student
called re Stowe or maybe an associate
made it we're not quite sure whether
they were you know on a pure level or
you know one was a student I Ursula said
that virtues the only thing that matters
and a difference we don't have to care
about them at all as a matter of fact
so long as we're virtuous that that's
great the only thing that could possibly
be bad would be being vicious and so you
know the Stoics rejected what we can
call indifferent ISM thinking that well
anything that's indifferent it's all
really on the same level none of it
matters very much and Cicero has Cato
tell us and there's no reason to think
that this wasn't Cato's review and
Cato's you would just be the Orthodox
don't you if we maintain that all things
were completely indifferent the whole of
life would be thrown into confusion and
no function or task could be found for
wisdom since there would be absolutely
no distinction between the things that
pertain to the conduct a wife and no
choice need be exercised among them see
for the Stoics in order to exercise
wisdom you have to evaluate things you
can't be totally detached from them you
can be detached in the sense of
recognizing that in different things are
different that they you know they're not
genuinely good or bad but that doesn't
mean withdrawing from them that doesn't
mean putting up a wall and saying I
don't I don't think about these sorts of
things you know if you think about the
people who do that it's usually
motivated by some sort of rejection on
their part this is you know we might
call it hyper ascetic attitude that
isn't genuine stoicism wasn't genuine
stoicism back in the day it's not
genuine stoicism for modern stoicism
Seneca and Leonard 92 he talks about
pursuing and using preferred
indifference and he says that taking
them as an exercise of good judgment and
some of the examples that he gives are
putting on clean clothing taking a walk
in the proper way and dining as as we
should and he says that the key thing
there is an intention of maintaining you
know proper measure that pertains to
reason and and you see what he's saying
there is that the wise person uses any
useless word natural tools and as
disposal or her disposal in order to
accomplish the right things and there's
actually a nice discussion there about
you know white
working for the human being you know and
if you think about this you can say
we'll use Stoics I think why do you care
whether I'm in rags that are dirty and
falling apart or you know putting on a
nice clean shirt and taking a shower
every so often why does that matter at
all isn't that totally indifferent I
think so yes it is indifferent but
you've been getting the body you've been
given the things you ought to use them
in the right way
letter 82 where he's talking about
courage he says that and this is very
interesting
nothing is glorious that does not
involve indifference illness pain
poverty death
none of these are glorious in itself but
nothing is glorious without them they
give us you could say the ballast
against which we can we can push off or
they give us something to fight against
or resist you says that the virtue meets
these and handles them another thing
that he says in that that letter is that
each object takes on a splendor not its
own when virtue is added to it so it's
not suffering as such that somehow it
nobles us it's displaying courage in
relation to suffering that is what it
nobles us a lot of people tend to you
know treat being victimized today as if
that somehow is heroic right and and the
Stoics would say no you can you know bad
things can happen to you and you can
have responses to them that are that are
not virtuous but rather vicious for
example just placing it onto other
people and repeating say a cycle of
abuse that you know that would actually
be a bad use of those things in on the
happy life was a really nice short work
if you haven't read that work by Seneca
it's well worth taking a look at he
talks again about wealth and I mentioned
we would get back to wealth he says that
the the virtuous person and the foolish
person might both pursue and use wealth
and Seneca was a rich guy right and
you know he drew upon his contacts in
order to make his money a lot of people
criticize him and say how could you be a
stoic when you were so rich what he had
to say and you can you know you can
decide whether you think that he's
entirely consistent with this or not
but I think that the general point is
quite good he says that the the virtuous
person in the foolish person both
couldn't pursue and use wealth but in
the case of the wise person wealth is in
servitude it's being used as a tool on
the part of the foolish person wealth is
in command so the desire you know what
we often call greed which the Greeks
recognized as a major problem back then
even as a special term for it play on
Exia right wanting more than you
deserved or thinking that money by
itself is going to provide you with
security or with happiness these are the
things that will will take people off
track and the Stoics recognize that when
people do that it's because they've got
some vicious dispositions they may be
foolish they may be unjust they may be
cowardly and power courage and cowardice
doesn't just have to do with fear can
also do with willingness to endure toil
you know it's called Philip onea or
industriousness or magnanimity rising
above things and then self-control so
one of the things that I think we want
to think about when we're talking about
the indifference and much of our life is
really concerned with these indifference
you know whether zoom works or not
indifferent right whether you know I
turn the lights on or off indifference
the coffee is is it n different all
these things that were surrounded with
we want to think about how do the
virtues you might say
just command from on high but penetrate
into all the aspects of our lives that's
that's what a stoic would say is
important you know correspondingly if we
find that we have vices we will usually
discover that they have also managed to
penetrate deep roots into all the parts
of our life that we have to slowly I
don't know if any did you do any
gardening there are some plants that
when you're reading you can't just pluck
it out right you have to like slowly
ease it out and get the root system and
then you discover that there's more of
that there and you come back the next
week and find that there's new sprouts
for that kind of plant these these sort
of analogies I think can be quite
helpful in thinking about virtue advice
so you know with each of the stomach
virtues will remind you know what they
are wisdom which not only has to do with
thinking about heavenly things but very
much about earthly mundane everyday
things what's good for us what's bad for
us how you know we ought to treat other
people
motivational structures and all sorts of
things that all falls in wisdom justice
how it is that we want to be treating
other people in practice realizing our
our social nature following through on
commitments that we've made those are
all aspects of justice courage I already
talked about that quite a bit and then
temperance or self-control which isn't
for the Stoics just about bodily desires
it pertains to all sorts of other things
as well that we we could have you know
wrongly oriented or wrongly structured
desires for versions about each of these
can apply to indifference and if we do
it well according to the stoic sort of
narrative we eventually become happy or
at least happier less miserable and if
we screw it up or we do it in a laksa
basically and don't pay attention to
what we're doing or tell ourselves all
sorts of false stories about you know
how courageous we are when we really
aren't we're going to be miserable
because of the way in which we've used
indifference the last thing I want to
talk about
that I think kind of ties this this
moral side together about use and
virtues many people when they first read
Stoica authors like marcus aurelius or
epictetus or seneca they come away with
this sense that the Stoics a very duty
driven that's all they talk about that a
lot right duties to do this you've got
to follow throughout them now again you
might say stuff is really indifferent
who cares why why should I have these
duties to fulfill and most of the duties
that we do in fact have or appropriate
actions if you don't like the word Duty
because it's got too much of a
moralistic sense just use appropriate
action there's a perfectly good
legitimate translation of the Greek
katakana the Latin efficient most of
these have to do with things that are
within the realm of the indifferent and
so I'll go a little bit further with
that Stoics would actually say that our
family our neighbors are strictly
speaking indifference to us as well we
have to qualify that pretty heavily they
are persons they do matter as persons
they are like their own you know little
world onto themselves but even the
people that I have been I'm closest to
my you know immediate family my
long-standing friends colleagues who I
hold in great respect they are something
external they are something and
different that doesn't mean that I don't
have all sorts of important relations to
them and this is where you know the
Stoics we can talk about there's
actually a really wonderful book by
Brian John's it's either Johnson or
Johnston called the role ethics of
epictetus that goes into this quite
quite well and you know the Stoics say
that that we have a whole panoply of
moral obligations that are essentially
arising from the relationships that we
either found ourselves in or have
willingly placed ourselves in and
fulfilling those is often a matter of
how we use indifference I'll give you a
just an exam
from my own life so my daughter is 18
now and is going off to college she's
actually coming up here to Milwaukee to
go to the University of Wisconsin
Milwaukee and enroll in the musical
theater program which was accepted into
and there's all sorts of decisions that
have to be made many of which have to do
with finances and you know filling out
paperwork and stuff like that now a
stoical would not actually say none of
that stuff matters
that's that's all just a difference how
I actually do those things do i do them
diligently do i plow through all the
different things that I have to do and
you know try to help her with finding
financial aid trying to model for her
what following through on these phone
calls would look like that you know
these are all within the scope of what
it means to be a parent I suppose you
could say all of those things bear out
indifference but they have the
possibility of creating virtue for her
as a developing human being and also
expressing I took I mentioned the
emotions earlier what the Stoics would
call familial affection feel lost or
gate which they thought was incredibly
important Marcus will also talk about
you know loved quite a bit these are
these are things that can be done with
me a difference within the framework or
the fabric of our relationships and so
what we do with them is not indifferent
what we do with them is either good or
bad or a mixture of both and you know to
bring this to a close what we can see is
that the whole notion of the
indifference is quite a bit more
complicated than its it's sometimes
presented where there's you know good
that's virtue bad advice everything else
doesn't really matter it's all in
different just withdraw yourself from it
that's not a stoic point of view and you
won't find that being espoused in Seneca
or Marcus or rapping Titas or and these
other works that I've mentioned and so
duties or moral obligations virtues use
these are all you might say lenses
through which we can see with the right
path at each moment that we need to take
with respect to these indifference are
that's all I've got it looks like I've
talked for maybe about 25 minutes or so
I know there's a lot of questions yes
so Greg that was great I'm going to ask
just one clarification question I want
to take kind of you know get out you
know I'm gonna not use the term
indifferent and I try to pose the same
question
okay so stoic ethic is a virtue ethic
it's a work ethic and the alternative to
that is a value ethic so I don't accept
that okay let me complete the question
and then you can disability so most
people kind of automatically start
thinking in terms of value ethic of
saying is this a value to me or is this
not to value value to me I
it looks like the term indifferent is
saying that it has nothing to do with
virtue indifferent is something that is
nothing to do with worship directly but
yes directly it doesn't have have to do
with virtue directly yeah but at the
same time it strikes seem to say that
there are values so values are being
expressed as preferred indifferent as
opposed to it so it so mapping this
terminal stoick terminology of
indifference into this is the way I see
it mapping into kind of virtue ethics
and value it does that is that fair or
is that well I'll say this so I think I
usually resist these kind of dichotomies
and splitting things down the middle
because when we get into substantive you
know looks at things
most most virtue ethics are quite
complex and do you have all sorts of
value aspects and a lot of ethics with
value everything about my Schaller for
example right there's plenty of room for
virtue and what he's saying
but let's say we accept that sort of
split I guess that could work I you know
there probably aren't any better ways of
talking about
what the Stoics call the indifference
and this was a problem even back in
their own time they coined this
terminology but I will say about what
you're proposing isn't worse I think
it's it's subject to its own these knees
wind up being technical terms right and
we have the same challenges as we're
using them
there isn't any nice intuitive like at
least in English maybe there isn't other
languages there's no easy nice way to
reexpress this okay that gets it across
and that's kind of a shame all right so
now I just want to give heads up to to
you Greg and to everybody else we've got
already eight questions in the pipeline
car and lots more will come as we start
asking questions so please keep the
questions coming the rule is that I will
call on people when I call on you just
unmute yourself ask the question and
mute yourself back no follow-up
questions we want to get to as many
questions as possible okay and keep
asking questions we'll just line up the
questions and let's try to keep the
answers also reasonably brief so we can
get to as many questions as possible all
right so I'm going to tell you the order
of questions now it's going to be inna
followed by Bartow Gill followed by
Helius Greg Kate
Alex Sam and Aurora you know you're next
go ahead I have a question does like her
opinions that other people have of you
do they might ermine as a difference in
somebody has a good opinions like a
public opinion like about something
about you is that the different of
different yeah so that's a that's a
great question and we can talk about it
like in terms of the individual and then
like you know sort of like larger scale
like you know what what your society
thinks about right so public we could
call it social status or public opinion
of one's self that's that's a preferred
indifferent right it's better if people
like you it's it's worse but not in the
sense of like
leading to happiness or misery if people
think that you're a bad person when
you're not right and a lot of our
judgments about other people are whether
they're good or bad people and water
spikes and so you can say that to about
the individual thing so if my my
daughter is mentioning in all she comes
up here to college and let's say she
decides that you know she starts taking
some classes and she's like I think my
professors are way smarter than my dad
you know I'm not gonna listen to him
about anything he's an idiot okay so
that's those are very strong judgments
and opinions about the Stoics would say
that's that's still within the realm of
the indifference and if I want to be
happy it's probably better not to care
too much about that now on her part as
the individual that she is it's not it's
not a difference because it's not good
to have you know wrongheaded ideas about
about things maybe it's not wrongheaded
maybe the the professor she has will be
better than me in that case it would be
quite good but you know we if I have the
wrong view about you that's an
indifferent to you from historic
perspective but that's not an
indifferent where I'm sitting because
I'm the one who's actually in some
respect damaged or harmed by having
wrong wrong views about things you know
think about products right so if I don't
like a certain brand of butter and I
won't buy it
you know I'm that's that's within the
realm of the indifference but if I'm so
fixated on it then I you know if I if I
need to use butter to make omelets or
something and I won't use it because
it's the only one in the refrigerator
I'm kind of badly off all right all
right so the next one um okay let me
remind everybody how folks are keep your
questions
ah just just a second okay I don't know
what happened it's back
all right um folks are keep your
questions as short as possible so we can
get to as many questions as possible and
keep asking more questions all right our
next up is about your guilt I'm not sure
I'm pronouncing the name correctly but
go ahead yeah that's right can you hear
me yes yes yeah so first of all thanks
so much for the talk I'm really big fan
of your YouTube channel and I follow a
lot of the videos and yeah first of all
I wanna extend thanks yeah
my question is mostly personal I'm very
interested in like what keeps you
internally motivated like especially in
philosophy and how do you like learn
about all of these philosophers these
concepts and how do you explain them so
clearly to people no those are those are
actually really good questions and some
of them I don't actually know the answer
to you know when you've been doing some
I've been studying philosophy either as
a student or as a professor for 30 years
now
and so some of these things become a
matter of habit and and it's hard to get
a good sense of like well what did i do
back then I don't really remember I know
that having to go through the the really
rigorous comps and preliminary exams
that we had back in the day that no
longer exists because they were kind of
an academic hazing was incredibly
helpful for me because I had to you know
learn mass amounts of the history of
philosophy and like store it all in my
head and it's sort of like going through
an intensive you know exercise regimen
your your body still retains quite a bit
of it later on
dad said it's you know I don't really
think that hazing is a great idea for
her people what I can talk about is so
the passion for philosophy and I can
talk about like being able to talk about
it in a accessible way I would say you
know in a way I'm
I'm kind of coasting on other people's
achievements I don't do a lot of
original work of my own and nor nor do I
want to I'm sort of like I tell people
I'm salesperson I'm selling Ariston or
I'm selling the Stoics and the product
that if I do a good job it sells itself
I really enjoy the things that I study
you know and people say who's your
favorite philosopher I don't I don't
have one because I'd like to read so
many different people and I see
applications to ordinary life I think it
also helps that I I didn't come from an
academic family and I never intended I
didn't intend originally to go to
college I worked and then went in the
military and came out and worked and
then finally went to college and my
first teaching jobs and my first main
one was teaching in a maximum-security
prison
and I've always taught what are called
service classes so intro to philosophy
ethics critical thinking and a lot of
professors view those is kind of like
slumming wasting my time with these non
majors I want to be teaching my you know
graduate level class on Hegel but it is
nice to know you don't get to teach
graduate level classes but the the real
apprenticeship for doing philosophy in a
way that can connect up with ordinary
people are those service classes because
you have a whole class of people who
don't want to be there and they have no
idea what philosophy is or if they if
they do it's probably you know they got
it from some high school teacher who you
know may have been cool or may have been
a jerk and you're gonna have to make
these things connect with them so doing
that year after year after year turned
out to be really good for me it
developed those skills and I and I you
know I think if you can it's one thing
to teach graduate students or even you
know philosophy majors they're already
sold on me the thing that you're doing
and they know the terminology and they
can come up with examples and they're
all chemical Kidder's anyway being able
to talk to business majors fashion
majors culinary arts majors people like
that
that is you know that's where you really
test yourself whether you can get ideas
across and and it's fun to I another
thing I'm going a little bit outside of
the scope of the question but I like
teaching those kinds of majors because
you can use their experiences and what
happens in their field for raw material
and say can Plato actually say something
about this that maybe if not them screw
Plato but usually it turns out they can
once once we dig deep enough next
question is from Helios
so let me tell you the order its Helios
Greg Kate Alex Sam Aurora
Francois Z and coal next vilius go ahead
hell yes you're on mute okay let's go to
the next person Greg Greg go ahead
our gregg we can't hear you okay let's
go to the next I don't know what's going
on with the let's try the next one
Kate go ahead hi everybody and that's
okay cuz I have two questions I'll keep
keep them brief okay okay sure so the
first one is if you can expand a little
bit about them idea that what is good is
what in accordance with nature I would
love to hear what that means and the
second one it seems is this I'm not sure
if I understood it correctly but it
seems as if there's a spectrum of good
in one hand bad bad on the other and
then indifferent in the middle and we
can have the freedom to make use of
either good or bad and what's in the
middle and they're indifferent and I'm
thinking can't we say that about the
entire spectrum that we can make we
decide what used to make out of
everything well you can't make good use
out of ice so it's not all sort of on
the same level and you know if you are
genuinely virtuous you're not going to
make bad use out of courage or wisdom or
things like that you could think of it
if you want to represent it visually
it's like you know you've got virtual
advice and the other associated things
that are genuinely good on a higher
level and then there's you can say
there's a spectrum beneath it of the
indifference but nothing none of the
value across that spectrum winds up sort
of leaping to the level of the good or
the bad
so well and now what was the firt the
first one again it was about what does
it mean that what is good as when it was
measured yeah so the Stoics think and
this is
in accordance with nature is a very
complicated idea it's one that I'm
actually writing a book about because it
gets it gets used a lot and there's a
lot of different discussions of it
running throughout the stoic texts in
sort of a thumbnail sketch of it
everything that exists has its
particular nature and you could say its
principles of development in this
respect that stomachs are kind of
similar to the Aristotelian Zoar or
other philosophers who think there's a
teleology to things and as opposed to
the other animals because we're rational
animals at a certain point we we move to
a different level and we begin to
recognize something that transcends the
natural impulses that we we have as
animals towards you know for example
staying alive and doing you know certain
things with our own kind we recognize
according to the Stoics the the value of
truth understood not just as something
useful but but having intrinsic value in
itself and we come to understand in some
dim way the right and the wrong as not
just being you know what produces you
know what we might call lower-level good
outcomes or bad outcomes and you know
that's that's one place where the Stoics
kind of differ from from other thinkers
like the Epicureans so developing that
that nature is part of what it means to
live in accordance with nature a lot of
it would involves living choosing acting
in accordance with the virtues and it
gets more complicated yet because when
we have the virtues usually we don't
have them fully developed so we're kind
of figuring it out as we go along the
picture gets clearer and clearer and
clearer the more virtuous that we become
and correspondingly the more vicious we
become the more
unclear it gets or we have the wrong
sort of clarity we think we have
everything figured out and we actually
have some quite wrong the next question
is from Gregg I'm gonna read it out
Gregg says I know you have covered
McIntyre in the recent past on your
YouTube channel can you compare and
contrast the stoic concept of virtue
being the proper use of indifference are
parenthetically playing the game well
and McIntyre's concept of gaining
internal goods within a practice well I
would say that's only part of what
virtue is but we you know we can we can
talk about you know proper use of of
indifference there I mean there's also a
virtual also use the things that are
genuinely good well to like say once
once friendship now McIntyre the the
notion of you want to say gaining he
would say like achieving or attaining
internal goods within the practice
internal goods are those that can only
be realized within a particular practice
or an analogous practice so he uses he
likes the example of chess you know it's
not the only game that you can develop
certain goods of strategic thinking and
all that you could probably also do it
with goal but you probably can't do it
with checkers in the same way or back in
the same way and there's there's all
sorts of other practices that he talks
about as well I would say that there's a
lot of overlap there but that we have we
have a different emphasis right McIntyre
doesn't think that virtues are just
about achieving internal goods either
and there's actually there's so much
overlap between McIntyre and Stoics even
though McIntyre and often say that
Anthony long wrote a piece specifically
saying hey McIntyre you you're talking
about the service Italian tradition and
all of these interesting elements of it
stoicism also has this as well so I
would say that if you look at what
McIntyre and soft has to say about
stoicism
you you come away with the idea that he
didn't he didn't read as deeply as he
probably ought to have and and I say
this as somebody who really you know
actually loves and respects MacIntyre I
got to study under him when I years ago
and I'll tell you that when it comes to
virtue ethics he's the genuine deal he
actually practices when the preachers
excuse me I don't want to say he's a
sage but he's pretty pretty darn close
yeah but even sages have pets or blind
spots to them so I would say that there
isn't that much there isn't that much
contrast between them they're
emphasizing different different aspects
okay our next question so let me give
you again heads up it's Alec Sam or or
offerin Swasey call Kevin and timin R
and s T next Alex you're next go ahead
great thanks for can't Iran is Alex from
Toronto yeah thanks for your talk I
really appreciate it actually that this
topic is coming up because there's
something here that for me is always a
confusing thing about Stoics and I guess
I'm wondering about kind of like the
deeper maybe the physics or the
metaphysics behind this question of
virtue versus and difference and so so
it seems to me like the things that
matter the things that have are good and
bad have to do with the use of our
freedom and the things that are external
in some way end up being indifferent and
for me that all opens the question of
the difference between mind and body for
the Stoics I'm one now there isn't one
there isn't one right so my material Sam
yeah right I've heard that but then how
do they make what is the difference then
between the sense of an inner inner
world or an inner who freedom and so
Marcus talks about this for example
going within oh yeah the inner Citadel
right something might be right yeah
Epictetus also talks about inner
Citadel's but there were the vices hein
so not all the inner Citadel's the place
is good
yeah I think it's better to look at it
as like the human being is kind of like
this this thing inside and there's like
a membrane whatever we want to call it
you know between them and the external
world but then there's all these ways in
which the external world penetrates into
us and we're connected with it you know
our desire goes out to neat things so
we're not it's not like there's like a
you know little boundary and that was
made of iron and everything inside is
our our freedom area and everything
outside isn't it's more like you know
and in a way it's sort of like we're
this this messy boundary that sometimes
like extends itself further out than it
should and then gets it's trying to you
know object lesson and don't do that you
know but then in a lot of cases has to
do that you know I mentioned it we're
doing stoic parenting meet up earlier
today and one of the things that we we
all talked about is how when you have
kids your whatever you want to call a
region of vulnerability to the world
vastly increases because you've got
these little creatures that almost seem
hell-bent on injuring or killing
themselves or doing stupid things oh
it's fine wait till they develop some
some you know guidance systems on their
own so I think that it's it's you know
the Stoics are materialists they they
think that you can use terms like soul
and body but what you're really talking
about is is something that's you know a
continuum of substance and I think what
they're saying fits in very well with
materialist ways of looking at things
now you know you think about our brains
or anything they are up here and but
they're kind look at what we're doing
right now we're in this communication
with each other it's not like we're just
these isolated things that are passing
signal smacking or if there's something
more happening and then you know every
time that that happens we we become
and so I think the stomachs are teaching
us how to manage that more effectively
if that makes sense
fully answers excellent next question I
just want to make sure that as many
people get a chance to ask the question
so let's not do our follow-ups so that
we can get to everybody Sam is next Sam
go ahead my question is essentially that
is there like some major chasm between
Epicureanism and destroy system in our
world Epicureanism is usually associated
with just you know wantin you know
gluttony and you know living the code
with life and quote but in the ancient
world or at least somewhat curious and
thought that you know all you need for a
good time is a bowl of figs and you know
conversation with friends which I mean
it's not quite stoicism but you know
it's not you know the Furious Living you
know that
yeah there were there were some real big
differences between the Stoics and the
Epicureans on some key issues so the you
know the Epicureans they they genuinely
thought that pleasure or freedom from
pain and trouble is good and everything
else has to be centered around that and
that would you know guide your practical
reasoning and decision-making in the
stomach said pleasure is a preferred
indifference it's nice if you have it
but you know you don't actually need to
have it and what's most important is the
you know the whole nest and the morally
good the noble power we want to
translate it and that led to different
ideas about how you ought to live your
life in relation to other people so the
Epicureans deliberately withdrew as much
as possible from what we translate as
politics but really it means social life
it means engagement with your neighbors
people like that now modern-day
Epicureans and there's a there's a large
neo epicurean movement out there
I think they've they've put quite a bit
of that aside they they are quite often
involved in
like paper hood groups were in local
politics or things like that but the
classic Epicureans withdrew as much as
possible Trump from that although I mean
it's interesting you you there is a
discussion of it in cicero's on the ends
buck one where this this one epicurean
tries to make the case that you know
everything that these other in virtue
ethics perspectives like the
Aristotelian starix everything that they
do we we've got that too but it's all
because it needs to have more pleasant
life I don't know that anyone was really
that convinced by it
Cicero takes a book to to deconstruct
all of that afterwards the Stoics
thought that you you really need to be
involved in your community not not in
such a way that you're like constantly
jockeying for power things like that but
they thought that you know you live
within a matrix of relationships and
those have duties and you shouldn't try
to withdraw from it and that there were
a lot of polemics between the Stoics and
the Epicureans on that very point so you
know i think you can say that they they
are there are some points of similarity
but even the notion of like tranquility
isn't the same from the Stoics to the
Epicureans let's go next to Aurora or
I'll go ahead my question is what is
your opinion and having standards isn't
having a standard a form of pride which
is this disparate burden different no I
mean
having standards isn't necessarily
prideful I think there are a lot of
people who sort of egocentric they
impose their standards in prideful ways
but you know the is we hold saying goes
the abuse doesn't negate the proper use
of other thing everybody's got standards
of one form or another even if it's just
what's good is what's good for me sure
egoist
so I don't I don't see how you can get
away from having standards the question
is whether you can get better and better
standards or not and you know it's
interesting me to bring up pride and I'm
going to like totally shift gears here
so one of the other people that I do
work on is John cassia this monastic
author and he talks he's he's one of the
people that we eventually get the seven
deadly sins from and in Christian
literature which were originally the
eight capital vices in the Desert
Fathers with casseon kind of ideas
Pontic us and he talks about pride as
being you know this really problematic
thing because it can use even the
virtues as raw material for its its
activities you know if I'm a courageous
person I could be prideful about my
courage right so there is there is a
danger to look out for there and maybe
the Stoics aren't sufficiently attentive
to that one of the common criticisms of
the Stoics made not in the ancient times
but in the Renaissance and early modern
period was that they were too prideful
about the capacities of human beings you
know that they didn't take into account
power but at that time they called
depravity what we could call our our
usual state of screwed up and us you
know so I may be the Stoics weren't
sufficiently attentive to that but I
don't think that having standards by
itself is prideful okay now last four
questions are from Francois Z our call
cabin and Timman Francois C go ahead yes
hi my question is about fun you know
because that's in that middle of of
Buddha
that you don't measure but fun is a
little bit different yeah what you call
indifference has always been a bit cold
to me so I find to be more of an
epicurean to have fun and I see between
your smile and your sparkling eyes that
you having fun with the stoic yeah were
you finding that's fun yeah and some
people think I joke around too much -
yeah me too
that's a great question if we look at
the classical Stoics some of them we can
say we're definitely not fun people Cato
was a great example you know really
wonderful guy
but I do not think there was anything
fun about him at all you know with
Epictetus there's some there's some
humor going on there but you got a
really like dig dig into it to find it
and this is actually a great question
because it's come up when we eat when we
like we have this annual stoic on every
year which unfortunately is going to be
virtual this this time around because of
the coded crisis but you know we all get
together and we like have presentations
and we talk about things and we do
indeed have a lot of fun together and
then some people come along and they're
like you're not being you're not being
properly stoic or if I say I'm excited
to go to Stoica well that's not a stoic
either I think that this is one of the
areas where there's the classical things
are not not that helpful for us and and
we're modern stoicism past and forge a
new path interestingly I'll tell you
this they do this psychological
assessment stuff with stone stoic Week
every year and one of the categories
that Tim Lebon found that the greatest
rise in what was called zest which is
closely it's not the same thing as fun
but it's closely related to it that's
like capacity to get enjoyment out of
life and he was like that's kind of a
weird result
why would doing stoic practices lead to
this and the answer that we never really
did figure out the answer maybe there's
something about doing the discipline
that liberates a space
which you can you can do that because
having fun requires spontaneity and a
certain kind of freedom right not to
take things so seriously but your this
is a very is a very good thing to think
about
yeah thanks oh you're welcome our next
question is from Carl yes thank you
if what we're Juan was interested in
creating an imaginary utopia other than
Plato's Republic would you recommend any
other philosophers who study utopia or
talk about the ideal well as it so
happens Zeno wrote a book called the
Republic as well and we just don't have
it unfortunately and it could be good
for the reputation of sysm that we don't
because apparently not only did he
advocate like free love but so that may
be cannibalism is okay and nobody nobody
quite knows what to make there were in
ancient philosophy I mean there's
literary stuff some of which is kind of
silly
like you know illusion of Sam soda I
don't know if you've ever read him he's
a very fun author he's a satirist and
he's also the first science fiction
author with his true history but I don't
know that anything he does is serious
like let's sit down and try to come up
with a blueprint for the perfect society
sort of thing I mean there's Thomas
More's utopia of course and there's a
lot of stuff coming after that about
perfect societies that you might say
there was actually a kind of cottage
industry there is there is an
interesting thing from a feminist
perspective Chris Christine de Pizan
book of ladies which advocates you know
like an ideal city in which women don't
have quite quite the hard time that they
have on the outside because of all the
stuff that the men are doing and taken
seriously
I don't know that says that's actually a
good question I don't have I don't have
a very good sort of synoptic view on I'm
utopian literature
unfortunately okay next up is Kevin
Kevin go ahead hi I just wanted to ask
do you see any parallels in the notion
of indifference with the losses notion
of difference would you say they're both
against the trope of identity yeah I
have to I have to punt on because it's
been a long time since I've been reading
anything other than logic of sense when
it comes to lose and I don't want to get
things wrong fortunately afraid enough
next one up is Tim and Tim and go ahead
hi thanks for doing this Greg where's
Karen yeah you mentioned briefly before
that more progress or moral development
is preferred and different can you
clarify what you mean by that is I seems
like an indifference or things we could
do without right can we do without moral
development not if we want to get to
virtue right but by itself I guess in
and this is something where I you ask
can i clarify it not not too well
because we're not quite sure what the
stories they say we get this one a lot
of hammered mark and then we get all
this letters left where the Starks are
constantly stressing how important it is
that we devote ourselves to moral
development and it's coming from
Diogenes Leontes who's not himself a
stoic but is reporting on what the
Stoics mother their standard doctrine
was so I mean the closest the the best
stand that I am at it is that they had
to place it in there because it wasn't
yet at the point of having attained the
virtues it's good if you can do it but
it doesn't in and of itself get you
there and that's a weird thing to say
because
if anything gets us to the virtues
wouldn't it be making the continual
effort from developing so it may be one
of those areas where the stomachs are
actually just in coherent but I don't
you know I I don't quite know what to
make a bit at this point alright folks
so that brings us to the end of the Q&A
so let me firstly thank Greg but I'll
come back to you I will give you the
last word here but let me tell you
what's coming up so next week we're
going to have dr. Walter Metro Chuck and
he's going to be talking about stoicism
and our EBT that is rational emotive
behavioral therapy on May 16th Gregg
Lopez our friend is going to be back and
he's going to be talking about the
difference between stoic approach to
mindfulness and Buddhist approach to
mindfulness on May 23rd
Massimo will be back and he will be
talking about pandemic as exile and what
Seneca would have to say about it so
that's what is coming up so now what
we're going to do is we are going to
split into groups of about five six
people each so we can talk about these
ideas ah you know Gregg has put a lot of
you know a lot of thinking material on
the table and we can talk about how it
applies to our lives so that's what
we're going to do so Gregg it was
honored to have you here and any last
words before we go nothing actually
comes to mind other than to thank you
for inviting me and all good questions
and I will say too having seen all three
of the people who you mentioned coming
they're all really good speakers so
you're you're all in for a treat
you